[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia en foco su
programa sobre la actualidad francesa el
tema central de esta edición son los
ucranianos refugiados aquí en Francia
desde febrero de 2022 cuando se
intensificó el conflicto con Rusia más
de 5 millones de ucranianos tuvieron que
abandonar su país muchos han llegado a
países de la Unión Europea Como por
ejemplo Francia que ya ha acogido a unos
109 mil de ellos En un primer momento
vamos a ver precisamente Cómo es todo
este proceso de acogida y de adaptación
de ellos aquí a este país y luego
hablaremos con un experto en tratar los
traumas relacionados con la guerra y el
exilio
[Música]
para facilitar la acogida de los
ucranianos en los países de la Unión
Europea Bruselas les acordó un permiso
temporal que es renovable cada seis
meses con él lo pueden trabajar estudiar
y tener acceso a servicios médicos todo
esto sin necesidad de pedir asilo un
trámite que es largo y bastante
engorroso alisa y ludmila son madre e
hija ellas tuvieron que huir de kiev y
han venido a encontrar Refugio Aquí muy
cerca de París donde están
reconstruyendo su vida Aunque su corazón
permanece en Ucrania donde todavía
tienen a su familia
Alicia llegó a Francia gracias a la
gimnasia artística comenzó a practicarla
a los cinco años desde entonces es lo
que le hace olvidarse del resto del
mundo tocó a la puerta de varios clubes
en Europa el de Antony la aceptó en ese
suburbio del sur de París vive con luz a
su mamá tras salir de Ucrania donde
quedaron su papá hermano y amigos
estaba muy contenta porque me postulé a
varios clubes y cuando me respondieron
fue una alegría me dije Ay Por fin
Alguien contestó
es una tal Ucrania participó en varias
competencias nacionales
me siento muy feliz cada vez que voy a
entrenar me conecto con el objeto que
trabajo me interesa saber cómo debo usar
mis manos y la música es muy divertido
para mí las competencias no me gustan
mucho entre nosotras las niñas del club
pero sí las competiciones externas
cuando he trabajado bastante y puedo
mostrar todo lo que tengo
este exigente deporte le ha permitido
conocer a otras gimnastas como ella en
el club gr de Anthony se entrenan 16 de
sus compatriotas desde el año pasado
entre ellas Valeria quien es entrenadora
hace cinco meses llegó a Francia
es en verdad importante para mí poder
compartir mis conocimientos mi
experiencia con estas jóvenes
la gimnasia en Ucrania ocupa un lugar
importante para las niñas el objetivo es
obtener resultados en Francia
después de encontrar En qué club
entrenar urgía hallar una nueva casa
para alisa y su mamá viagala las
acogieron los primeros cinco meses de su
llegada
Tratamos de que todos se sientan a gusto
abrimos todos los armarios y dijimos
Esto va Aquí Esto va allá luego las
cosas fluyeron de manera muy simple muy
sencilla con mucha fraternidad estábamos
felices de poderlas acoger
es una experiencia genial maravillosa
nunca las habríamos conocido Claro que
las circunstancias no son las mejores
pero es enriquecedora a alguien Sí
son como mis abuelos
[Risas]
el aprendizaje del idioma francés Es una
etapa clave para integrarse cada jueves
una decena de ucranianos van a clase de
francés en este colegio desde marzo de
2022 una profesora ucraniana es la
encargada de dictarlas
creo que puede incluso ayudar a nivel de
ánimos quizás porque yo entiendo lo que
está sucediendo en Ucrania en este
momento
y como Y cómo puedo animar a los alumnos
el resto de la semana estos alumnos van
a clase en otro colegio con estudiantes
franceses así progresan más rápido
les gusta mucho jugar Incluso en francés
Así que esos juegos lúdicos son un medio
de aprender el idioma y muy pertinente
para los estudiantes de estas edades
Cómo les fue con nosotros actores me
gustó su grupo
a sus 14 años alisa habla Además del
ucraniano ruso inglés y francés
tuve que aprender francés para poder
hacer los ejercicios con mis compañeros
de clase y con eso puedo también hablar
francés cuando mi mamá necesite así
puedo leer los documentos del médico y
demás Eso es en realidad muy importante
para poder ganar su sustento ludmila que
en su natal Ucrania se desempeñaba como
gerente aceptó trabajar como aseadora en
julio pasado obtuvo un contrato a tiempo
indefinido su motor el futuro de su hija
lo más importante para mí es que puedas
continuar con tus estudios Yo no
necesito pero tú debes seguir
vivienda trabajo escuela en un año alisa
y su mamá han logrado integrarse pero su
corazón sigue en Ucrania donde permanece
en su padre y su hermano a pesar de la
situación tratan de hablarse por
teléfono Cada día oled y sacar siguen
la hermana no no
normal a una sociedad
la familia Espera que sacar pueda venir
a Francia para continuar con sus
estudios cuenta con la documentación
requerida pero por la guerra Ucrania no
deja salir a ningún hombre en edad
militar
es muy triste porque nos hacen falta
queremos verlos pero no podemos ir a
verlos
a pesar de las dificultades seguimos
siendo optimistas eso es lo que hace
Nuestra fuerza ante la adversidad la
familia se mantiene unida y en contacto
incluso con la abuela que sigue en el
don Bass y que de vez en cuando logra
llamar para tener noticias de los suyos
nos encontramos con el es psicólogo
clínico del centro primo Leví con el
Vamos a abordar los temas que tienen que
ver con la tortura con las personas que
han tenido que huir de la guerra entre
otras cosas más gracias por acompañarnos
mi primera pregunta es cuál es la labor
que ustedes hacen aquí en el centro
primordial
es una asociación que fue fundada en
1995 y que Acompaña a las personas que
han sido Víctimas de la violencia
política y de la tortura
vimos la historia de alisa y de luz nida
esa madre e hija cuando personas como
ellas vienen hacia ustedes Cuál es la
primera etapa que se hace con estas
personas
primero las personas son recibidas por
el funcionario que está encargado de
acogerlas se hace una entrevista donde
explica por qué fue víctima lo que
ocurrió porque hay que respetar ese
orden es algo muy específico cuando se
habla de tortura y de violencia
luego tiene una cita ya sea con un
médico o con un psicólogo y luego
decidimos entre nosotros como orientar a
esta persona si hay problemas sociales
que es lo que casi siempre sucede
por ejemplo estas personas que tuvieron
que huir de la guerra Qué tipo de
traumas o de síntomas presentan
podemos tal vez diferenciar que hay por
una parte del traumatismo y por otra del
exilio en el traumatismo se estuvo
expuesto a algo real algo que viene a
fijar ciertos síntomas
es el horror de la Guerra el horror de
la violencia debe haber reminiscencias
traumáticas alucinaciones traumáticas
y algo que puede parecerse a una
sintomatología psicótica Pues los
síntomas pueden ser muy diferentes
insomnio crisis de angustia crisis de
ansiedad
la mayoría de los pacientes tienen
problemas de sueño bastante importantes
Pero sigue ese hilo traumático que
regresa sin cesar es un poco como si
hubiera una pantalla entre y yo y los
pacientes de alguna manera es como si
estuvieran en otro lugar mientras que en
el exilio hay un corte abrupto con todo
lo que pudo forjar la identidad de la
persona es de verdad como un corte
porque ya no se tiene ni el idioma ni la
familia ni la seguridad ya no se es
dueño de su propio destino ni tampoco de
sus sueños y la idea Entonces es la de
poder volver a poner las cosas en marcha
Porque con el traumatismo las cosas se
quedan fijas
y justamente entre las personas que han
llegado a Francia o en todo caso que han
huido de Ucrania hay adultos pero
también hay niños en realidad hace las
Naciones Unidas la mitad de de los
refugiados son niños en este caso Cuál
es el seguimiento que hay que dar
lo que sucede cuando hay violencia
política tortura o en la guerra es que
puede haber una inversión de los roles
en el seno mismo de la familia y tenemos
mucho cuidado con eso por eso es que
también trabajamos con intérpretes no es
la única razón pero eso permite que cada
quien pueda expresarse en su propio
idioma
porque lo que Suele suceder es que los
niños aprenden mucho más rápido el
idioma del país de acogida y van a
servir de intérpretes son quienes van a
abrir los correos de la Administración u
otro tipo de correos Y de alguna manera
vienen a ocupar un lugar de adultos
le pagó
mientras que los padres parecen que
perdieran su lugar y es algo que es muy
complicado eso también puede llevar a un
sentimiento de vergüenza que puede venir
muy rápido él no estar en capacidad de
trabajar por ejemplo algo que es muy
complicado En todo caso hay una especie
de destitución del lugar de los padres y
para los niños es muy importante que
puedan tener un lugar para ellos que les
esté dedicado y por eso
[Música]
para todas estas personas que han tenido
que salir de sus países que han tenido
que vivir de una guerra por ejemplo
es difícil también poderse proyectar a
futuro estar en una situación un poco
incierta no saben si van a poder volver
a su país No saben Cuándo van a poder
hacerlo Ni tampoco si van a poder ver de
nuevo a sus familiares Cómo ayudarlos
finalmente a eso a proyectarse en un
futuro
la hipótesis que tenemos es que uno
puede autorizarse a cuidar de uno mismo
a tomar su tiempo a tener un seguimiento
si hay una parte de la familia que por
ejemplo está en medio de combates o que
está combatiendo eso es muy delicado
también nos hicimos una pregunta durante
la guerra en Siria porque recibimos muy
pocos sirios durante el conflicto puede
ser que haya también un sentimiento de
culpabilidad me pregunto si puedo de
verdad autorizarme si es el momento
oportuno también si estoy en el tiempo
de hacerlo porque resisto de alguna
manera es como si estuviera combatiendo
a distancia mentalmente o por necesidad
de ser solidarios y no siempre Parece
ser el buen momento para recibir
cuidados
Bueno pues muchas gracias por todas esas
explicaciones gracias por haber estado
con nosotros
hasta aquí esta edición de Francia en
foco continúen con nuestra programación
en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]